You can't outrun destiny — and the destiny
for Netflix's The Witcher is another season.
Based on Polish author Andrzej Sapkowski's
Witcher novels and shorts that were turned
into a video game series by CD Projekt Red
, The Witcher was already lined up for a second
season prior to its official debut on December
20, 2019.
The action-fantasy show, created by Lauren
Schmidt Hissrich, takes place in a medieval
world within a realm called the Continent,
and follows the lives of three unique but
linked-together characters.
Throughout the first season's eight episodes,
viewers saw how the trio were molded by their
individual experiences before meeting one
another and The Witcher season 1 finale concluded
with Ciri asking Geralt,
"Who is Yennefer?"
With The Witcher season 1 ending on that delicious,
cliffhanger-y note, fans are understandably
foaming at the mouth for any and all information
about season 2.
Though details are sparse for the time being,
here's everything we know about the second
season of The Witcher.
The Witcher season 2 doesn't have a confirmed
release date as of December 2019.
However, when the series' renewal was announced,
it was reported that production on the new
season will begin in London in early 2020
in preparation for a 2021 launch date.
It wasn't specified when in 2021 The Witcher
season 2 might premiere, but it's most plausible
that fans won't be seeing more of the show
until the middle of that year at the very
earliest.
That said, the production timeline for The
Witcher season 1 shows a two-year-and-seven-month
gap between when the project was confirmed
in May 2017 to when it premiered on Netflix
in December 2019.
While it certainly won't be that long of a
wait for The Witcher season 2, if production
is slated to begin around February or March
2020, fans could be looking at a summer 2021
debut date unless Netflix allots the cast,
crew, and creatives more resources and funding
to speed things up.
it's a given that the major players from season
1 will be back for the series' second go-around
on Netflix.
The trio's individual paths cross at the end
of season 1 of The Witcher, and in Sapkowski's
written works, they experience many trials,
tribulations, and triumphs together after
meeting.
"What, you know this woman?
Of course you know this woman."
When Netflix confirmed that The Witcher would
receive a second season on the streamer, creator-showrunner
Lauren Schmidt Hissrich noted in a press release
that the show's team was keen to, quote, "continue
telling the stories of Geralt, Yennefer, and Ciri."
That doesn't give us much to go on, but given
that season 1 pulls from Sapkowski's The Last
Wish and Sword of Destiny, it stands to reason
that season 2 of The Witcher will focus on
the first few books of the main Witcher saga:
1994's Blood of Elves, 1995's Time of Contempt,
and/or 1996's Baptism of Fire.
But we're getting ahead of ourselves here.
The truth of the matter is that no one involved
with The Witcher has said anything explicit
about the plot of the series' forthcoming
second season.
Speaking with CinemaBlend, Hissrich teased
that The Witcher season 2 will only expand
on the characters and plots showcased on season
1, saying,
"[Season 1], of course, carried a lot of weight
because you're setting up the entire world.
You need to set up all of the characters,
you need to set up the politics, you need
to start to understand what a witcher is and
what they do and how that's changing in the
dynamics of the world.
The first season carries a lot of weight,
but there's a lot of things that we did this
season to set up events that we know we want
to happen in season 2 and beyond."
In a separate conversation with GamesRadar,
Hissrich doubled down on these comments, saying
that, quote, "all of the relationships that
we've been setting up in season 1 actually
start to come into fruition in season 2."
She further noted,
"What's great about season 2, I can tell you,
is that, in what we've written, the story
becomes much more focused.
There's a stronger drive in the story [...] Characters
start meeting and interacting more.
That goes well sometimes.
It doesn't go well sometimes.
But it's kind of like, all of those building
blocks that we set up for the world, finally
start to come together into something a little
more concrete."
Hissrich has also said that she has seven
seasons of the series mapped out, so there's
much, much more Witcher goodness to come...
if Netflix chooses to make it so.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Witcher
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.